good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today
his SCP 915 ein object class safe
special containment procedures SCP 959
is to be sequestered in a six meter by
eight meter room and cypher with
adequate furnishings and reading
material for comfort with an SCP
guidelines only personnel who have
passed psychological screening may
interact with a CP 959 all personnel
entering the room must obtain a copy of
the photograph in the file tray next to
the door as a reminder that what they
are observing is in fact the phenomenon
SCP 9:59 exhibits this photo is to be
placed back into the tray upon exiting
any overtly aberrant behavior exhibited
by personnel beyond mild revulsion must
be recorded and said personnel
transferred to other duties after
further screening sees them fit to do so
SCP 959 is not to be given any food
outside of diet prescribed by physician
due to recent diagnosis see addendum 959
a subject is not allowed outside of his
room without an armed guard present at
all times for protection and only during
exercise regimen see addendum 959 a SCP
915 ein is allowed standard personal
grooming equipment and access to a razor
and moustache wax to maintain his
appearance so long as no tendencies
towards self-mutilation are shown under
no circumstances is SCP 915 ein allowed
to interact with other sentient
scps unless for the purposes of testing
and only by express written approval of
doctor
under no circumstances are any personnel
who were previously assigned to a CP to
31-7 to be assigned to SCP 9:15 ein due
to more information see video attachment
to incident report description subjects
ability initially activated on 2000 at
airport during the boarding of flight to
see incident report the manifestation in
question only occurs when a sentient
being is looking directly at a CP 959 he
then takes on the appearance of someone
or something from that beings past
memories that was the cause of greatest
personal discomfort this reaction seems
to be completely involuntary and
continuous regardless of whether SCP
9:15 ein is asleep or awake reactions to
the manifestation have ranged from mild
discomfort each d-class personnel
exposed during testing reported seeing
something different exclusive to that
individual see document 959 one a the
area of effect seems to extend to
approximately a 37 meter radius in all
directions as long as the subject is it
within direct line of sight
manifestation does not occur when viewed
through a secondary electronic source
such as a camera mirrors however do not
seem to be a deterrent to the
manifestation even perceived as mocking
them SCP 959 still sees a reflection and
mirrors as normal at time of this report
SCP 959 is a 35 year old Caucasian male
with brown eyes bald head and a brown
handlebar moustache standing
approximately 1.6 metres tall and
weighing 137 kilograms
these features can only be observed
through cameras or indirect viewing at
range due to the manifestation
addendum 959 a upon admission to succor
SCP 915 ein underwent full medical
screening tests confirmed SCP 959 is
currently suffering from mild adult
onset diabetes and has been prescribed
oral medications along with a diet and
exercise regimen that must be adhered to
application of scp-500 considered but
rejected as the condition is considered
to be reversible and not
life-threatening
if the physicians instructions are
followed antidepressants have also been
prescribed as the isolation due to the
manifestation is taking a negative
psychological toll addendum 959 b has
been classified safe after exhibiting no
signs of the desire to escape doctor
addendum 959 c months after being
brought to the foundation the subject
has requested to be involved in
foundation matters claiming I want to be
of use in some way SCP 959 believes the
foundation to be a positive influence on
the world despites and could be abuse
during interrogations subject was warned
that this would be highly unlikely but a
request was submitted and is pending a
determination doctor I didn't really
want to waste anyone's time on this but
just saying it would make the poor
bastard stop crying
watching him crying while looking like
really made me feel ill doctor document
959 one a experiment blog
subject NSEP 959 placed in a two cell
chamber while off from one another with
a 10 centimeter thick sheet of
shatterproof plexiglas SCP 915 I was
told to sit in a chair and not speak
subject D 959 one result subject stared
shook his head and muttered for
approximately five minutes before being
asked what he had seen subject replied
he looks just like my dead brother and
wasn't able to subject was escorted from
the room without incident subject D 959
to result subject began to apologize
profusely
apparently believing the manifestation
to be her mother subject made promises
that she would the subject had to be
forcefully removed from the testing
chamber and sedated subject D 959 three
result subject immediately began
screaming in a high-pitched
incomprehensible tone and started
clawing at the door and tried to attack
the guard when it was opened subject was
terminated lip-reading specialist on
sight believes what was being screamed
was subject agents result subject stared
at SCP 915 ein for approximately five
minutes before being asked what he was
looking at subject suddenly began crying
and confessing
subject had to be removed and sedated
upon removal of the subject as CP 959
vomited and asked that the testing be
halted for the day okay I'm gonna need
to put in a formal complaint to whoever
compiled this document there is no need
for this level of redaction folks I'm
sorry I'm sorry
if you're eventually gonna be
researchers doctors whoever you're gonna
be formatting documents this level of
redaction that you've just heard is
completely pointless I am I get it I get
angry I really do get angry there are so
many even towards the end I just
substituted the D class with a number is
it's not hard there D class people they
don't have identities whatever the
original D class number was it doesn't
matter you just put in a number people
reused D class numbers all the time they
don't have an identity man and check
your wording please I apologize for that
R and it wasn't very professional I know
whenever you've read as much of these
documents is I have you start to
appreciate well formatted documents also
SCP 915 ein is diabetic did I miss
something
what does diabetes have to do with
anything maybe I'm being too critical I
mean I I will hold my hands up and admit
if I'm being too critical there is no
need to put that in the document is
there someone tell me if I'm missing
something I will hold my hands up and I
will admit
[Music]
anyway thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye oh man
I need a [ __ ] vacation this is
Nicholas I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Wookiee Jax Merrick ki
Labuan slump God John Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball Cody tench
cheese whip dips McGee on dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]